I downloaded the neo demo on its last
day and I've made a mistake this game is
amazing and I have less than 24 hours to
play it so I opened my notepad I start
taking a few notes on the game and then
I discard that idea because I do not
intend on putting this controller down I
have this legitimate hunger for the
combat just to dive in and kill enemies
and push a little bit further than I got
last time and that's a damn good sign so
here's what I learned and here's what I
was impressed with from my short time
playing in this game stamina is called
key and it's key that you manage your
key and the key of your opponent with
this new information you have the power
to see how far your enemy can exert
themselves when they're about to
overextend and when the right moment is
to overwhelm them and punish them right
off the bat this adds a huge depth to
the combat system but most importantly
perhaps stamina vision affords you this
reassuring feeling that the opponent's
you're facing are operating on the same
rules that you are as a player the game
itself isn't trying to kill you the AI
within the game are and I think that's a
humanizing rule of design that more
games should follow especially games
like this that go even beyond Dark Souls
in terms of how hard they are an
additional mechanic to make stamina more
interactive is the key pulse
if you press r1 a moment after expending
your key then you'll perform this pulse
which immediately regenerates the key
you just expended the amount is
signified by this fast-moving blue bar
and doing this pulse properly forces
this flow upon combat which if followed
appropriately gives you a huge key
advantage over your opponents and it
just allows you to attack like an
absolute demon provided you can keep up
the appropriate pacing also this pulse
can cleanse the aura given off by
enemies from the yokai
it's this black fog that if you step in
it stops you regenerating your key so
performing the pulse to cleanse this
felt to me like a forceful way of
teaching me that the key pulse habit is
probably one I should get into
unfortunately I didn't during my time in
the demo and I have a huge feeling I
made the game much much harder for
myself because I didn't start doing this
but anyway all of this makes neo the
first souls like game that I've played
that puts stamina at the very core of
the game where it rightfully belongs
this fits into this combat system that
rewards awareness and it's not just
awareness of stamina it's also awareness
of the attacks of enemies of course and
in these kinds of games enemy attacks
should have two parts there's the
forecast of the attack and then there's
the attack itself there's this raising
or lowering of the weapon than the swing
allowing you to predict and react the
animation is fantastic for the most part
except on some of the larger monsters
for example this one boss had this spin
attack that I never really felt like I
deserved getting hit by and they need to
be careful to get this right because I
think it's the most important thing
about the combat one thing that took a
lot of getting used to is the sheer
variety of move sets that are available
to both you and your opponents in neo
there is a selection of weapon classes
like spear hammer katana and jewel
katana and while every weapon within
that class appears to share the same
moveset every class of weapon can be
held in one of three stances so high
stance gives you powerful but slower
attacks low stance gives you fast but
weaker attacks and mid stance is
predictably the balance between the two
and in each stance you still have access
to light and heavy attacks and these
attacks are different depending on what
stance you're in so basically you can
swap a TAC style on the fly and that
feels fantastic it's quite like
blood-borne in that
regarde just instead of having two
weapon states every weapon has three
weapon states and it means you can
proactively adapt to combat in a way
that you never really do in souls games
giving you access to thrust attacks
overhead attacks fast attacks slow
attacks all regardless of the weapon
you're using and you might already be
thinking about this but the obvious risk
here is that because you can cover the
weaknesses of every single weapon by
changing stances that weapons might
struggle to feel unique because what's
the point in using a great hammer if I
can just put it in a light stance to
attack quickly or what's the point of
using dual katanas if I can put it in a
slow stance to make them more powerful
so yeah this does affect the
individuality of weapon classes and sure
you could argue that yes the low stance
of the duel katanas is still faster than
the low stance of the great hammer but
there's so much coverage here and this
approach does mean that weapons lose
some individuality but do I want it
changed nope like I said it feels
fantastic to have complete control of
your weapon and the only thing holding
you back in combat is really your
awareness and your knowledge of how well
your stance will fit the situation I
think that build diversity is going to
struggle a bit in the long run because
of this but there is so much depth to
the combat that I don't see this being a
big issue and for all the individuality
weapons lose from stances they do gain
some character back with the option to
learn weapons specific abilities you can
invest talent points into new abilities
which are specific to each weapon class
like the powerful spin attack of the
great hammer or the wily trip attack of
the spear and also you can find the same
type of weapon with different rarities
and attributes and that helps make your
weapon feel a bit more unique I'd also
like to praise the level design
particularly for the way that these felt
like real coastlines real villages real
forests and elect the way they blended
environments together and
all the while they were hiding a bunch
of estes shards physical shortcuts and
most notably ambushes because of these i
was progressing slowly peeking around
corners and just listening for that
audio cue that signals you're in trouble
there was no real cue for this happening
however and speaking of falling
I like how knocking enemies off edges
was actually encouraged by the level
design and the combat because if you
strike an enemy towards the edge then
they'll clip into this falling animation
that's incredibly satisfying to pull off
and this ability to jostle for space and
knock enemies off ledges it's supported
by the combat much more than insoles
because if you hit an enemy in this game
or if you take a hit there is a lot more
back step and movement during attacks
that you need to take into account now
it is possible to comfortably run past
enemies but this demo had a lot of
decent choke points that's something
that Dark Souls never does well you can
always sprint past stuff and then
initiate the invincibility frames when
you're opening a door but no in this
game if you're climbing a ladder and you
get hit once you fall off and good luck
killing a mini-boss that's a required
kill when you're followed by all the
enemies that you've accrued from running
for 5 minutes straight I was always
punished for fighting in unfamiliar
territory and that's a good thing
you're also rewarded for fighting some
enemies as the youkai monsters don't
respawn if you've killed them once which
allows them to serve as a sort of soft
checkpoint system and I probably
shouldn't talk about the game too much
longer because I didn't get enough time
with neo to talk confidently about it
but man considering how much fun I had
with it and how hyped I am for it now I
just couldn't resist making a video but
rest assured when this game does come
out on February 19th 2017 I will try to
make the best damn neo video you've ever
seen but for now I'm going to direct you
over to three channels there's Tara
mantises channel he has a great video on
neo
multiplayer and I'm going to direct you
to a smaller channel I found called
hustle habit for a chilled-out
discussion about the depth in the game
and also silvermont has this fantastic
video talking about how well the
developer listened to feedback since
their previous demo which you really do
have to give the dev props for from his
video I got the impression that they
literally took his advice on some topics
and they've even reached out to me to
hear what scant feedback I have and
that's super humbling and very promising
we've covered a few souls like games at
this point some of them take the souls
formula and they apply it cleverly to an
entirely different 2d perspective some
take a few elements they twist them and
they build them up and turn the game
into something else and sometimes
something better these little risks and
show how the formula of souls can be
improved and they're the way these games
can continue to feel fresh and I'm
expecting a lot of great things from neo
when I pick it up for ps4 so thanks for
watching guys and I'll see you in the
next one